did you know that Craigslist is the 79th
most visited website in the entire world
in fact Craigslist beats out several
Heavy Hitters including Target Yelp
Shopify and even Snapchat with 250
million monthly active users Craigslist
isn't that far behind Amazon themselves
who boast just over 300 million monthly
active users though it should be noted
that Amazon Shoppers are likely way more
trigger happy it's not clear how many
dollars worth of transactions happen on
Craigslist every year but with that much
scale in market share Craigslist could
easily be a multi- decillion dollar
company even if they just charged a
modest fee of 3% per transaction if they
charge something more substantial like
Amazon of 8 to 45% they could probably
be a hundred billion company but in
reality Craigslist is nowhere near those
figures in fact Craigs List is lucky to
even pull in $1 billion per year because
they don't make a single scent on the
vast majority of Craigslist transactions
which is by Design Craig Newark the
founder of Craigslist definitely wanted
the venture to be viable and profitable
but he was never looking to create a
tech Juggernaut his primary goal was
always just to connect buyers and
sellers with no BS or Thrills for as
cheap as possible and given that north
of a billion dollar translates to nearly
$20 million in revenue for each of his
50 employees Craig has never tried to
take monetization to the next level in
fact that's why Craig's List looks like
it hasn't been updated in decades that's
because it hasn't been of course Craig's
team addresses any ux issues or bugs as
soon as possible but in terms of playing
the UI game and maximizing user
retention they're just not all that
interested as far as they're concerned
they've created a reliable platform that
serves a purpose if that interests you
great if not no worries as you can see
Craigslist is basically the antithesis
to everything big Tech stands for
whether it's infinite growth maximum
profits or unlimited funding but while
they may not be the most lucrative
website in the world they no doubt one
of the most impactful so here's the
insanely humble rise of
[Music]
Craigslist taking a look back the story
of Craigslist dates back 70 years to
December 6 1952 to Morristown New Jersey
Craig Newark was born to a middle class
Jewish Family that was pretty ordinary
his parents held jobs like being a
bookkeeper an insurance agent and a meat
salesman that was until Craig turned 13
and his father died of cancer at which
point everything became a lot harder if
this was a Dar man video this might have
been some sort of insane pivotal moment
the point at which Craig realizes that
he has to fend for himself starts a
business and works his way up but in
reality this was nothing more than a sad
and depressing time for Craig he didn't
have much of a social life to begin with
and now without his father he was not
only a nerd but a broke nerd with thick
glasses held together with the tape and
I don't think being part of the school
choir the physics Club The Debate Club
and the Honor Society really helped
Craig's case either according to Craig
himself he was possibly nerd patient to
zero to help him with his social
troubles and the passing of his father
Craig was regularly sent to therapy
sessions with his school counselor but
his counselor eventually gave up on
therapy and just taught him to play
chess instead over time things did get
much better for Craig financially after
graduating high school in 1971 Craig
would attend Case Western Reserve
University there he earned a bachelor's
and MERS in computer science and entered
the buring industry of tech Craig would
score a programming job at IBM straight
out of college where he helped
Enterprise customers like Bank of
America and Sun Microsystems Implement
IBM Solutions this was akin to Landing a
job by Google today so little to say
Craig never really had had to worry
about broken glasses or really money
ever again but other aspects of his life
didn't quite improve in the same manner
specifically his dating life and it's
not like Craig didn't try either in fact
Craig would join ballet and jazz dance
classes to meet women but given that he
wasn't exactly in the best shape of his
life he would end up at the hospital
with a hernia before you knew it Craig
had been working at IBM for 17 years and
he was in his early 40s at this point it
seemed like Craig's fate as a lost geek
who spent his entire career at a legacy
tech company was basically sealed but
Craig wasn't willing to accept that he
felt that what he really needed was a
completely Fresh Start in a new city
with new surroundings so with the burst
of energy in 1993 Craig would quit his
job at IBM get a new job at Charles
Schwab and relocate to San Francisco and
just as Craig hoped this would indeed
turn into a major turning point in his
life unlike Detroit where he used to
live in San Francisco computers were not
the nerd thing to do but the cool thing
to do Craig started socializing with a
bunch of computer geeks who hung out at
cafes and discussed the Revolutionary
future of tech and it was during one of
these fateful sessions that one of his
co-workers from Schwab would introduce
him to something called the worldwide
web and this would completely change the
trajectory of Craig's
[Music]
life Jeff Bezos was introduced to the
internet around the same time he saw
that the internet was growing by
hundreds of percent every year and saw
massive opportunity Craig on the other
hand saw something completely different
from his perspective the internet was
the perfect gateway to network with
other like-minded individuals and
finally build a social life and that's
exactly what he did he started regularly
emailing all of his friends from work
about tech events that they could attend
together often times his friends would
forward these emails to more friends who
in turn forward them to even more people
pretty soon Craig's emails started
reaching dozens of people most of whom
he didn't even directly know seeing this
interest Craig came up with the idea to
create an email list that people could
easily join to stay up to-date with the
local Tech events and that's why it's
called Craigslist it started off as
Craig's personal emailing list pretty
soon Craigslist would grow into a strong
local community of hundreds of people
who suggested that Craig turned the
email list into a website and with that
Craig would whip together a simple site
that let people post about local events
and craigslist.org would go live in
1996 to Craig surprise people would
start using the site for things other
than social events almost immediately
we're talking about job postings
recruiting discussions and so much more
which brought in a lot more people
despite this massive influx of users
though to Craig Craigslist was still
very much just a social thing it had
made him somewhat of a legend within the
Silicon Valley Community and he loved it
all of a sudden he was being invited to
the best parties around allowing him to
meet Tech leaders that he had never even
dreamt of meeting but by morning time
Craig was back at his desk at trab as a
hardcore Java engineer it was until
years later in 1999 that Craig actually
started pursuing Craigslist fulltime in
classic Craig fashion though it was
nothing flashy he basically just rounded
up nine engineers in his apartment and C
it away it turned out that one of these
Engineers was a superstar though Jim
Buckmaster Jim had a very odd background
as he had basically spent his entire
adult life at College he didn't have a
bunch of degrees to show for it though
you see Jim was actually a medical
student at the University of Michigan
but he had stopped seriously pursuing
that by
1986 however he would spend the next 10
years at College just taking one class
per semester while doing odd jobs so
that he could keep all of his student
perks eventually he would stumble his
way into California at which point he
would post his resume on Craigslist in
hopes of finding a job and it just so
happened that Craig himself would hire
him truly quite an odd backstory but
don't let that for you Jim was an
absolute beast in fact he was the guy
who took Craig's hobby website and
turned it into a serious business he
created a robust search engine at a
discussion forums developed flagging
features designed the homepage and most
importantly led a nationwide expansion
seeing this Rising Superstar Craig would
give Jim D Reign to the company and
promote him to CEO and November of 2000
a position that he's held ever since
over the next couple of years Craigslist
would grow a massive Nationwide presence
but there was still one major issue the
company didn't make any
[Music]
money in 2004 Craigslist would begin
charging users of certain categories for
the first time Craig very much wanted
the website to stay a free community
resource so he mainly started monetizing
users with profit incentive for example
users were posting job openings or
apartment listings Craig started
charging $75 per job listing in San
Francisco and $25 per job listing in
other leading American cities they also
charged $10 per apartment listing in New
York City many users started fearing
that this was the beginning of the end
for Craigslist its slow descent into
maximizing profits and honestly if
that's the direction that Craig took I
don't think anybody could really blame
him he had created a massive Marketplace
connecting hundreds of millions of
people so wanting to monetize such a
community is only natural not to mention
he had a bunch of pressure to do so as
well you see after Craigslist started
charging for postings eBay decided to
get involved they would purchase a 25%
Stak in Craigslist from ex employees
hoping that Craigslist was going to
double down on monetization but Craig
never went down this path which really
pissed off eBay in fact eBay would
actually end up suing Craigslist for not
doing right by their shareholders and
not focusing on revenue and profit
growth but after years in court eBay
would just give up and sell their stake
back to Craigslist in 2015 and to this
day select job and apartment listings
are the only way that Craigslist makes
any money that's why they don't even
cross the billion dollar Mark in Revenue
despite having a quarter billion monthly
active users none of this is to say that
Craigslist isn't lucrative though while
they don't have an insanely High Top
Line they do have an insanely High
bottom line given that they run an
extremely lean operation with only a few
dozen employees Craigslist is often able
to boast net margins of 70 to 80% so not
too surprising that Craig has crossed
the billion dollar Mark over the years
and most of his employees are quite well
off as well as such Craig has largely
stepped back from his role at Craigslist
and has mainly been focusing on
philanthropy for quite some time now in
fact it's not uncommon for him to donate
more than 100 milli million dollar in
any given year and his donations don't
go to your classic save the African kids
or save the environment type efforts
either rather his donations are often
much more nuanced he likes supporting
efforts that create a more fair and free
internet less biased journalism greater
cyber security and more support for
Veterans for example if you've ever
wondered what type of person makes large
donations to websites like Wikipedia
well you've got your answer but putting
all that aside I think what makes Craig
truly unique
is that he's still just a regular old
Craig if you saw him walking down the
street you would have no idea that he is
the Craig from Craigslist he was never
really interested in becoming super rich
or super famous or anything eccentric
like that Craigslist was just something
that kind of happened by accident and he
ran with it as wholesomely as he could
and I think this statement really
captures Craig's entire Mission I'm
committed to customer service for the
rest of my life death is my exit
strategy and that right there is the
insanely humbling story of Craig Newark
and Craigslist unlike Craig big Tech has
decided to go in the complete opposite
direction and it turns out that they're
now running out of people to convert
onto their platforms check out this
video to learn more about Big Tex and
game but until then I'm Hari and I'll
see you guys on the next
one